So there's a great scene near the
beginning of shame,
blacks,
the nice guys,
which more people should have seen in
theaters,
by the way,
you know what?
Fuck the angry birds.
Anyway,
we're Ryan gosling.
A private investigator breaks into a bar
to get his hands on some receipts like
we've seen people do a million times
before in movies.
Gosling is going to break the glass to
unlock the door from inside,
but things really don't go as planned.
Besides being a hilariously funny
reversal and subversion of an old
cliche,
I think this moment gets to the heart of
Shane.
Blacks interests in awkward violence and
deeper than that in film,
new wars,
obsession with violence as the undying
backdrop to civilization.
Speaking of backdrops,
you made not be familiar with Shane
Black,
but his work has been in the backdrop of
Hollywood for 30 years now,
starting as a writer during the SPEC
script boom of the late eighties,
nineties,
and early two thousands when unsolicited
original scripts were really high.
Demand Black wrote lethal weapon one end
to the last boy scout,
long kiss goodnight.
Then went on to direct his written work
in films like kiss,
Kiss,
Bang,
iron man three,
and finally the Nice guys.
All of these films share similar themes,
so I'll have fractured characters all
take place in dangerous,
often.
See me.
Worlds all have whipped fast plots,
reversals,
betrayals,
and plenty of character revealing
banter.
In other words,
they all share the traits of film noir.
There's a certain madness,
I think in a certain bizarre quality of
violence in the war films where it's
devastating.
It's just ongoing.
It's not just clever.
It's devastating.
At this point,
we're clearly not lacking in violence at
the movies.
Blockbuster and tent pole films are a
wash in this stuff.
Explosions,
car crashes,
chases,
fights,
you name it.
There are some directors and stunt
coordinators who are really good at it.
For example,
the Captain America Franchise I think
has mastered a very sharp part hitting
type of superhero violence where other
franchises have struggled to meet that
bar,
but the thing about violence in
superhero films is that it's fun,
but never really that consequential,
particularly if it's heroes fighting
heroes come on,
black widow,
you know these people are slated until
like 20,
22,
right?
A lot of these films add violence to the
mix to spice up things every 20 minutes
or so,
they write themselves up to the brink
and then let the stunt coordinators take
it from there,
making sure a few beats or hit along the
way.
This isn't necessarily bad.
Sometimes it's awesome,
but it's not all that violence can do.
The question you should be asking isn't
where you should add violence,
but how can you use it?
Take that scene from the beginning.
With gosling,
it accomplishes so much in such a short
period of time.
It subverts that cliche for comedic
effect.
It's a quick reversal of narrative
momentum.
It shows how hapless gosling's character
is,
and an accidental slitting of the risk
plays into the deeper sadness that
underlies his drunkenness.
I kind of 40 and slit shane black is a
master at using violence to augment
story and character in his action.
Thrillers and neo wars want to show that
a police detective his past his prime.
What if you want to show that a
detective craves violence in an almost
masochistic way in blacks films,
the violence is often messy and shocking
and awkward because that's what real
violence is like.
It's a kind of chaos,
a rupture in things.
The inciting incident in a long kiss
goodnight is a perfect example of this.
Gina Davis hits a deer with her car,
which would be enough to send the car
careening off the road by itself,
but black has the deer come through the
windshield,
still alive,
kicking the passenger in the face.
This is awkward and transfixing in a way
that leaves us on guarded against the
violence of the moment.
In consequence,
we become more present for the whole
scene.
The pencil trick in the dark night,
by the way,
achieves a similar effect.
Another thing black likes to do is visit
violence on an otherwise piece.
The thing that black likes to do is
visit.
Maybe
I should just let black say it in his
own words,
in this country where we think
everything's settled and stable and
serene,
something horribly violent can intrude
upon our piece and then we have to go
back to this gunslinger who knew all
along that the war wasn't over in the
west,
wasn't gentrified,
black uses sudden violence not only to
shock the audience,
but as a way to justify an animate his
heroes and heroines.
The point is that this is violence with
narrative purpose.
That purpose may be as simple as keeping
the audience on their toes or fingers,
finger,
yeah,
it may be a way to solve a simple
problem or it might reveal what a
character's really like or who he would
like to be.
Just we all live around violence,
but by and large were separate from it.
A good new or thriller lets us travel to
the other side,
dip our feet into that current,
feel,
how cold it is,
if we've had the bad fortune to
experience it firsthand,
we know that violence can be
indiscriminate and deeply personal at
the same time,
violence done right in these movies.
Violence as a plot element or an
exhibition of character.
Awkward violence is violence,
respected.
Of course,
at the end of the day,
these are just movies,
pulpy,
detective stories,
genre flicks,
but I wouldn't want to live in a
universe that didn't have pulpy genre
detective movies like lethal weapon or
kiss,
Bang,
Bang.
I think Shane Black is one of the few
action thriller writers who incorporates
violence into his scripts creatively and
I'm glad he's still getting work for
that to keep happening.
Of course we have to keep going to see
his movies and it.
Unless that is your okay with the
alternative
to the birds.
There is a new nerd writer video every
Wednesday,
so if you go right to that box right
there and click that,
you'll subscribe and get all the videos
and that's what helps me out the most in
this channel.
Um,
I gotta think squarespace for helping to
sponsor this video,
funding the channel without asking to
interfere in the content,
which is really,
really cool.
Um,
they make sleek,
intuitive websites.
You don't have to know coding to make
one.
And if you go to squarespace.com
and sign up for one year,
you'll get a free domain name.
And if you use the offer code
nerdwriter,
you'll get 10 percent off your first
purchase for all you website heads out
there.
Thanks so much.
I'll see you guys next Wednesday.